Sí muy buenos días para ti Raúl sucede
luego de que la asamblea nacional
retomara al período legislativo logra
vacancia legislativa el primer punto que
ha decidido discutir ha sido el caso de
María Belén Bernal básicamente el
parlamento aseguró que realizará Las
investigaciones y fiscalizaciones
sobre todo tratando de no politizar este
caso ha sido un caso que ha tenido mucha
presión mediática y De igual forma mucha
reacción por parte de la opinión pública
en este país pero cuáles fueron las
exigencias de María la madre de María
Belén Bernal y Elizabeth otavalo
básicamente ella
expresó su testimonio de lo ocurrido en
la desaparición y posterior asesinatos
de su hijo y básicamente lo que ella
denuncia es que existe un espíritu de
cuerpo por parte de la Policía Nacional
básicamente ella está cuestionando Que
desde Los Cadetes hasta los altos mandos
encubre lo sucedido en la noche del 11
de septiembre cuando se habría
denunciado la desaparición de María
Belén Bernal otros cuestionamientos que
hizo durante tres presentaciones en el
parlamento ella asistió a dos comisiones
del parlamento y luego expresó su
testimonio ante el pleno de la asamblea
nacional ella aseguró que existe un
espíritu de cuerpo también aseguró que
cuestiona que no existe un parte
policial específicamente del asesinato
de su hija ella cuestiona que no se
conoce quienes estuvieron durante la
noche que desapareció su hija porque
ella denuncia que muchas personas
escucharon los pedidos de ayuda por
parte de María Bernal pero nadie acudió
a ayudarla y por ello ella también exige
Las investigaciones por parte de la
asamblea en nacional también asegura que
se reunió con la fiscal general de la
república y una comisión especializada
de básicamente ella Pide a la asamblea
nacional aclarar Porque existen ese
momento dos procesos de investigación
uno reservado y otro específicamente
para los abogados Gustavo rápidamente
mientras esto sucede me el presidente de
Ecuador ha realizado algunos anuncios
vinculados a la lucha contra la
violencia de género cuáles fueron estos
anuncios de Guillermo lasso
Pero principalmente el presidente de la
república Guillermo lasso se reunió con
todo el gabinete principalmente mujeres
su gabinete y a su salida de ella ha
expresado que fortalecerá la política de
prevención de lucha contra la mujer y
específicamente
anunció que llamará a un acuerdo
Nacional para la lucha contra la
violencia de género ha dicho básicamente
que llevará a un acuerdo fiscal para
conseguir así los presupuestos y De
igual forma también llama a un acuerdo
nacional para luchar así contra luchar
de género anunció que en los próximos
días decretará una serie de medidas para
fortalecer así la lucha de género contra
la mujer